What do our end users actually want?
Are we making it better?
Are we building a platform
that will stand up?
What is right? What is that?
What are we doing?
Why are we doing it?
How does it connect to our vision?
And then it's ultimately like,
are we delivering it?
I'm so glad to have you here.
All the way from Uber,
TripActions, now Loom,
and Teach for America before.
I can't wait to talk about Product,
VP of Product roles,
and really, your insights
into those various industries.
But before we start on all of that,
I want to go all the way back
to Georgetown,
you're playing rugby.
And how that has
you know, hinted towards your life
as VP of Product?
I mean, I've been a big believer
in team sports in my entire childhood.
So, I've played more soccer
in my lifetime than rugby.
And then I went to college
and I just wanted
to pick up something new,
be part of a team sport.
So, I found myself up
on the rugby team on my freshman year.
It was super fun.
I still remember my first try.
It was like, I caught the ball
and I just remember the coach be like,
"Run, run, run."
And I'm like, "I'm running."
It's great. You have no idea what you do
and you're like, "I wish to do my best."
"I'll be sprinting."
We don't have much rugby in Israel.
But rugby is the sport where eventually
just everybody is piling
on top of each other over this, you know,
cone-shaped ball. Right?
Yeah. It's like huge in,
it's huge in Australia and South Africa.
It's pretty popular in New York as well.
But anyways, so then after college,
I really wanted to do something
that mattered.
And I just thought, Teach for America
would be a great place to contribute.
I had had the joys of like
a great public education system.
And obviously I went to a really strong
private university for college.
And I just, I wanted to contribute.
And I wanted to do something
with high levels of ownership
and something that mattered.
And so, I was lucky to be selected
to be part of Teach for America.
So, what is Teach for America?
What is the sort of impact you're trying
to make on the public education space?
Yeah, sorry, that's a great question.
I should start there.
So, Teach for America is,
it's been around for over 25 years now.
It is a non-profit
that takes high performing leaders
from quite a bit directly
out of undergraduate university.
But some put collegiate
and places them
into high need school districts.
So, the public education system
in the United States
does have a teacher shortage
and a teacher recruitment shortage.
And so, I partners
with high performing leaders
puts them through a distinct training.
And then you work in high need schools.
And so, what were your various roles?
Because you've done quite a few things
within Teach for America.
But it's not like you came in and said,
"Okay, I'm going to be a teacher,
I'm going to help others
in one capacity."
But you really branched out
and did quite a few different things.
And I'm especially curious for that
because, you know, looking from your
journey from an outsider,
you're saying, okay, you wanted to go
study in sort of politics government
in Georgetown.
And then you go into Teach for America.
And then you find yourself, you know,
going straight into high tech
at full speed,
both at really big companies like Uber,
then to medium size companies
like hyper growth, like TripActions,
and now to Loom,
which is more of a startup scene. Right?
So, I'm really curious
to hear about the journey
and how you sort of paved this road.
Yeah. I mean,
so, a core belief of Teach for America
is "teaching is leadership".
And I think that, I didn't know
at the time that like,
learning about teaching
and working at Teach for America
was preparing me in many ways
for what I do now.
You learn, how do you get people excited
to go after big goals?
How do you break it down
into medium goals?
How do you build a culture?
How do you keep going
even when things get hard?
And like, the results are coming in
and you need to change course.
Like that is all, I mean,
those are some of the many things
that product organizations do.
And it's the same in a classroom.
And so, I think
it was a really good foundation
in terms of building ownership,
taking tough blows.
Teaching is so hard,
and then continuing to keep going.
And when I left Teach for America,
I had joined the team in Dallas
and had been working
on developing Proofpoint schools with,
sort of attracting school leaders
and high caliber teachers,
and in trying to work with the district
to make Proofpoint schools.
But I just wanted to,
I was really young and you know,
things were moving
really fast, career wise.
And I just realized that I wanted
to experience something different.
I wanted to challenge my brain
in different ways.
So, I tried to applied for Uber,
got into Uber
and then kind of navigated the company
to get to what I was like,
ultimately more interested in,
which was on the product side.
And then from there,
I joined TripActions.
And the way that I found TripActions was,
I basically went through
a process of like,
Okay, who are VCs I believe in.
I have to understand the problem.
Like, I want to be excited
by the problem.
And then I met Ariel and Ilan,
and then it was kind off to the races.
And I had also looked for startups
that had ex Uber executives.
You know, Uber is a mixed bag.
You know, 2014, 2015, 2016,
Uber, they're like highs and lows
from a culture standpoint.
But I do think it was rigorous
and bold and courageous.
And there were, you know,
negative attributes as well.
That coin is double sided.
But like, when I first joined there,
we all believed in it so much.
And I knew that I wanted
to work at a company,
that that belief was like fully there.
Right.
And so, then I joined TripActions
when we were 40 people.
I had no idea that it would like, scale.
And so, yeah, I was
the first product manager.
Amazing. So, first product manager,
but actually pretty quickly
then becoming Head of Product
and then VP of Product.
And how many people were TripActions
by the time that you left?
So, when I joined,
we were a series-A, 40 people.
When I left, we were 1200
valued at four billion.
And my team went from just me,
to then running the design
or really building the design
and product organization,
to about 27, split between
Palo Alto and Amsterdam.
Unbelievable.
Why Amsterdam?
That was more
of an engineering-driven decision.
There had been another, well no.
Amsterdam,
because from an operations standpoint,
we had set up a support team.
And then our CTO had flown out there
and had met with a startup
that was very talented
in the travel space.
And so, then he made the decision
from an engineering perspective,
we're going to hire there.
There's also like
a ton of tax incentives in Amsterdam.
It's like Amsterdam and Dublin,
very interesting for startup
But anyways, so, it was mostly like
the operations team had set up
and then our CTO had gone out
and had met like a team
of pretty talented engineers.
And so then, it just became
kind of a natural decision.
Also, because TripActions
is both a product
and an operations company.
Right.
And good for your tech team
to be close with the support team
or your operations team.
Your customer success team,
your sales team, there's just a ton
of empathy that's developed.
So, it was kind of a win all around,
both from a product
and engineering and a support perspective.
What were some
of the most both challenging
and exhilarating things
about moving from a,
you know, one person team really
to now, almost a 30 person team?
But more importantly than that,
being a part of the incubation
of what would become a 1200 person,
four billion dollar company,
which I'm assuming
as one of the first people
working on product in the company,
you've gotten to see really
the vision and strategy
unfold along the way,
as you made those transitions.
So, I'd love to sort of pick your brain
and fast forward during these years.
But really understand,
what were some of those insights
that you gained throughout this time?
I mean, I think
the first ones that come to mind,
and since you didn't send me
the questions ahead of time,
I have to just go off the cuff.
The first is like,
as you begin to build a team,
the people you bring in are so exciting.
Right.
I think about some
of the product managers
that I hired, that I mentored,
that I learned from,
and it's just so fun, you know.
Yeah.
And I think,
that is just like a very inspiring piece
of a company growing.
And then I think the second piece
from a product perspective
that I learned in spades
at TripActions is like,
you should always be responding
to the market.
Right.
Like if you want to be winning
and if you want to be a true partner
to your customers,
because TripActions and Loom
are both B2B2C, like you need
to be both over delivering
and also have a pulse
on how things are changing.
Right.
So, how do you then, as VP of Product
have that pulse?
How do you wake up every day,
and by the way,
one of the questions
that before we start, you're asking,
"How do you edit these videos?
What software you use?"
I guess that's part
of the VP product mentality
of constantly doing that market research.
But what is your,
sort of engaged responsibility
with the market?
How do you tangibly go
about executing on it every single day
as you're aligning the strategy?
And when Ariel and Ilan are saying,
"Okay, we'll Anique,
what is the next product
we should build?"
then, how do you even go about thinking
of that new and innovative vision?
It's a good question.
I mean, I think part of it is
being pretty diligent about always
being in front of customers.
So, like, if I look at my week
and I'm not like
in the field at least twice,
I'll like, being
customer success in sales
and be like,
this is a lonely week.
Like I need to get out there.
And what does that mean, Anique?
What does that mean
to get in front of that customer?
Is it literally, you picking up the phone
and calling customers?
Is that you going to meet ups or Zooms?
I push in
on customer calls and sales calls.
And I also, if we're going to lose a deal
or if this was like,
if there's something at risk,
I want to know from it.
Because, one, it's my responsibility,
but also because
there's so much learning to happen.
But still about this, you know,
jumping in, being responsible of them,
they're still learning,
that's part of both leadership,
but it's also a part of, you
understanding that it's a process.
And, you know, you have
to learn from every experience.
So, from your insights,
what are some
of the most important things
that a product manager
can take with them
as they're building other product
and strategy and growing in the ranks,
as regards to a company's product?
I mean, I think the first
is like curiosity.
I think one of the mistakes
that product managers,
that it's funny when I join
as a customer into product meetings,
that I face sometimes is product managers
being defensive of their product.
You're seeing uncomfortable, right?
You're like, "Oh, it's criticizing."
And so, that art of listening
and balancing being empathetic
and being genuinely curious,
while also taking ownership
and taking responsibility of the product
that you've developed,
I think it's a really, you know,
it's a balance that everyone
is trying to constantly get better at.
Right.
And there's definitely times
where I hop up calls where I'm like,
I didn't listen enough.
Or I should have asked
more open ended questions than I did.
What is the difference between
open ended versus closed ended questions,
from a product management perspective?
So, let's say that I'm now, you know,
I'm the founder of an early stage company
and I'm trying to get my validation
or I'm trying to get some insight
into whatever I'm building,
what would be a key indicator
whether I'm asking the right questions?
Because I think that
that's both something
that I need to get better at.
But I think that it's also something
that I see quite frequently
that people don't ask enough
open ended questions
when they're doing their research.
It's like asking,
do you use X tool versus
tell me about
how you edit your videos?
Right?
You're going to get
so much more information.
You're going to learn
about their workflow,
what their technique is.
And you want to know
all of that information.
You want to like
be consistently learning about it.
Right.
Because that will
inspire future decisions.
I think building that gut
and that instinct is so important.
And we've talked a lot
about customer calls,
but it's also like, you know, one of my,
like strongest product managers
in my current team
is like, we should just be using
different video services every week.
Just like constantly be like
just building our gut.
Because I don't think
you can be curious enough.
Right.
And also, like,
what are other products
that you're using daily
or that other people are using
and what makes you love them.
Can you be conscious of that.
When you're signing on to you're like,
we are using Riverside.FM,
there was I clicked a button
and there was a great user feedback.
So, I took a picture and screenshot it
and sent it to PM.
So, that's why it took me a second to get on.
Right?
It's like, can you constantly
be building that instinct
of what makes great product?
Right.
Because different people
are really strong at different things.
So, it's like what's going on
in the actual market, right,
like the investor market, competitors?
What's going on with your customers,
to your sales,
to your support team?
Like make sure you're getting in there.
And you actually should be on the calls.
And then the third piece
is just like learning
from different types of products.
100%. And I think, by the way,
that one of the things that I enjoy most
about these open ended questions,
even more than quantity of information,
it's the surprise element
that when I hear something
that I didn't expect
or that I thought that,
that wasn't going to come out
of their mouth, and all of a sudden
it opens up a whole new world to me
that if I ask them more
of a closed ended question,
I'm sort of bringing
my preconceived notions
into the answer.
And it becomes almost
a rhetorical question
where I'm guiding them towards
a specific response,
or at least I'm barricading them
to some vertical
that they have to, you know,
they have to reside in.
Whereas the open ended,
I find that really, I'm getting
a breadth of different world views
and things that I really didn't expect.
But Anique, I want to make sure
that we have also enough time
to talk about what you're doing now.
Because I think that,
yeah, go ahead.
And I feel that I didn't answer
your original question.
Because I got too excited
about the curiosity.
To me, it's like in terms
of great product management,
I think it comes down to like,
curiosity, leadership and execution.
I think that you need
all three of those things.
If you have execution without leadership,
then the teams aren't going to be happy.
You're only going to execute once.
But those are the three to me.
And obviously, if you have curiosity,
but you don't have the execution,
then you're going to write
some great confluence papers,
but you're not going to end up
building a product people love.
But Anique, today you're working
as VP of product
in one of the startups
that I enjoy most, mainly
because I use it probably
50 or 60 times a day,
with pretty much everything that I do,
which is Loom.
Loom has developed quite a bit
since I began using it.
And I've been really,
really enjoying the product.
So, when you talk to me
about this customer delight
and the feedbacks that also
the user is getting and you're getting,
I can really see that in the product
that you're building there.
So, as the VP of product,
tell me a little bit about what Loom is,
and what are some of your thoughts
behind building now a product?
I'm pretty sure,
on a smaller scale now
than with Uber and TripActions, right?
But now you're seeing
that fast growth as VP of Product.
Yeah.
So, Loom is a video messaging product
that essentially allows you
to instantly create a video message
and get a link generated
and share it to other people.
And the reason why I joined
is I had a tremendously difficult time
giving design feedback
to the team in Amsterdam
when I worked at TripActions.
I would sometimes sound like
overly harsh over Slack.
And with time zones, you'd have like
two hours to work.
And so, Loom enabled me just to create
very quick, like, feedback loop.
Yes.
And like, the intent
and the effectiveness
and the efficiency of Loom
was like just a magical experience.
And I think, ultimately,
and then if you ask yourself
a few questions as to like,
why is it so effective?
Why is it so efficient?
Right.
Like the original form
of communication was storytelling.
Right?
What are we doing right now?
We're just telling stories
back and forth.
Loom is an incredible, like product
to put that kind of storytelling,
that human voice, that efficiency,
that effectiveness, like in the forefront
of how you work,
especially in a distributed work setting.
Which I think, like we
all currently are in, and in the future
we'll be in a totally different way.
So, it's a little bit about Loom
And a little bit about
what your role as VP or Product.
Is it exactly the same responsibilities
you've had in TripActions, for example?
What are some key differences between,
you know, that a VP product might have
in one company versus the other?
Because obviously, the title is the same.
But I imagine that
the scope of responsibility
is pretty different
amongst different organizations.
I think the responsibility between TripActions
and Loom feels pretty similar.
The major difference is design sets out.
Like we have a design leader
that runs the design organization.
But I think, ultimately,
the responsibility is, what are we doing,
why are we doing it,
is it the right thing.
Right.
Like, what we ultimately believe
is our responsibility to our customers.
Right?
Like, what do our end users actually want?
Are we making it better?
Are we building a platform
that will stand up?
What is right? What is that?
What are we doing?
Why are we doing it?
How does it connect to our vision?
And then it's ultimately like,
are we delivering it?
And delivering it by like,
when we said we were going to
at the quality we said we were.
And then how can you build
an organization in a team
that is constantly learning
and constantly improving.
So, we just get better and better
at this dance.
Right.
And so, you joined Loom
in August of 2020,
pretty much at some peak
of the pandemic.
There were so many peaks that,
you know, every day was almost
the peak of something.
And so, you joined Loom,
remote collaboration,
becoming, you know, diving deep
into this relatively new industry
that is very different
from your previous industries.
And so, what are some of your thoughts
behind the remote collaboration,
the things that you're observing
within Loom that you've gotten to know
over the past, I guess,
four or five months or so?
So, I do think
there are some similarities
between TripActions and Loom
in the sense that they're both B2B2C.
So, you're prior may be a company,
but ultimately both products rely
on your end user loving it. Right?
And that's like
kind of connected to Uber those roots.
And so, being very connected
to the consumers is really important.
But I think, you know,
when I joined Loom, I was really excited
about the effectiveness and efficiency.
Like, Loom can just help people connect,
especially like global workforces.
I think as I've
you know, gotten to know the product
and understand
Joe and Vinay's fuller vision
and experience the product myself,
it's incredible how much the Loom product
has the potential to really elevate
the culture of a distributed workforce--
I completely agree.
--in that cultural aspect,
and what it can contribute.
It makes your culture
more effective and more efficient.
But it also makes the culture
more rich, more human, more lively.
And I think until I started using Loom
in the way that I do
and starting to talk to customers
that are using it in that manner,
it's just an incredible,
like the potential of Loom
is just so huge.
And I have to say, Anique, that I have
to testify to this myself.
I have quite a few people
that I work with across the seas
in various countries.
A lot of them are dependent
on my feedback on a daily basis,
you know, every few hours.
And then the difference between moving
from a Slack feedback
or a WhatsApp feedback,
to now me recording
a 15, 20 second snippet,
of me demonstrating on the screen
my feedback, with my bubble showing there,
and me smiling and talking
or even just being casual,
it changes the whole relationship.
It changes the dynamic.
And I'm seeing it
just to boost the productivity
on all fronts.
And I think and again,
I love what you guys are doing.
So, thank you for really making
my work better and more collaborative.
And for many of my friends
and colleagues.
I know that a lot of people
that are using it.
I don't want to take up
much more of your time because I know
that you're already running late
to your next thing.
But I really appreciate you
taking the time to do this.
My last question,
which is my favorite one, is three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
I think maybe three would probably
be greedy, loyal and adventurous.
I love it.
Anique, thank you very, very much.
This was wonderful.
And stay safe and stay healthy.
So nice to meet you.
Thank you so much for having me. Bye.
Thank you.